Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast and Ah,
just checking in on you.
Whew.
I'm just checking in on Y'all are you?
How's your week going?
My Week is going fed fucking tastic man.
I did my special,
I taped it.
It is done.
It's in the can as they say in my business and now just needs to be edited.
Some port pastures.
Got to look at the footage and try to put that mess together.
I want to thank everybody that came out to Royal Albert Hall in London,
England.
I could not have had a better time.
Um,
I just,
just a couple of magical nights out there and hopefully it'll show up on the
digital recording that we made.
Yeah.
Somehow that it will,
that will be conveyed.
Um,
so now I have no act and uh,
I was like,
you know what,
man,
I'm just going to stay away from the comedy clubs.
I'm just going to go live some life.
You've heard me all that yoga teachers shit.
I was saying just going to go live some life and I'm going to let the next hour
come to me.
And I was literally thinking already tonight,
I've been back for fucking 24 hours being like,
maybe I'll go down to the club tonight,
Dan.
I just go fuck around.
No,
I am going to learn how to relax man.
Hello.
Sit down and just fucking eat an avocado for whatever the fuck it is.
You people do that.
Know how to relax.
Yeah,
you guys fascinate me.
You people know how to relax.
You know what I mean?
Like you'd go to a hotel and you actually put on the robe,
right?
You get the slippers on and shit and then you fucking order room service.
You eaten like chocolate strawberries from Sherry's berries,
whatever the fuck it is.
She do.
You know you have a spa day.
Um,
I,
I know I'm making fun of it but I,
I am fascinated
by that.
I want to be that guy,
that guy who knows how to fucking chill man.
Cause I don't know how to do it because this is what I do.
I go out and my two and fucking standup and then I go,
you know what I'm gonna do?
I'm going to get fucking 20 hours in the air in a helicopter,
or I'm going to go fucking play drums for fucking 30 hours.
Just my,
I just fill the time up.
You know,
you fucking people who could just sit on a porch,
you know,
I can't do that unless I'm slowly killing myself with booze or a cigar,
you know?
I can't just sit on a fuck,
give it just walk by,
you know,
and one of these sleepy southern towns,
you know what I mean?
Where they still think like Lyndon Johnson is president,
right?
You just walking down the fucking street and you just see somebody sitting on a
porch reading a book
and it's just,
you know,
that person,
they got it figured out.
You know what I mean?
They walk into church on Sunday,
their head held high.
They've got nothing to confess.
The fuck did they do?
Huh?
What does the big sin that they peaked a few pages forward,
hoping that there'd be an end of a chapter to give their eyes a break,
you know,
disrespecting the author and all the hard work that they put in.
Um,
yeah,
I'm going to try to fucking chill out here at least for three days.
I'm going to try to do,
uh,
nothing,
but I mean,
I also have a table read tomorrow for F is for family.
So that's something
and uh,
whatever,
what are you gonna do,
you know,
haven't shit to do is better than having nothing to do right around my fucking
that up.
What's the,
because at that fork in the road,
I chose boo boos rather than we'd,
you know,
the people who choose,
we'd,
they liked the people that like,
you know,
their dream in life is to retire.
Yeah.
And people who drink their dream in life is to tell people what to do and the
people go out and do it.
All
right.
I'm painting with a broad brush here,
but that's what I do on this podcast.
All right.
None of this is fucking necessarily worked out.
You know,
there's the occasional goddamn setlist.
All right,
let's,
let's go.
You know what I always do when I go to put together a new hour is I have to go
topical.
Let's say what said the news?
Everybody.
R Kelly.
Okay.
Bobby Kelly.
My good,
my old roommate just playing Magoo obese,
but the other art Kelly the singer,
right.
I'm trying to think of one of his fucking songs.
I used to know,
I used to know his songs.
Then they took the,
the videos away from MTV.
Like the last one I saw that he made was the one where you was sitting down and
he had half his head braided while summer was Braden is the other part of his
fucking head.
You know,
and God knows what happened to that poor woman judge you by that fucking debacle
of an interview.
Okay.
Hi.
It's me.
It's my love Audi here.
Fight for my fucking life,
man.
Like
he is,
he is fucked.
That's okay.
All I got out of that I had not yet.
Uh,
I am an innocent man accused of some shit that I didn't do.
What I,
the vibe from that
is I am fucked.
Um,
they got me this time.
God dammit.
Um,
yeah.
Well,
you know,
it was fucking hilarious when that guy was standing up screaming and yelling and
that woman just sat there,
right?
How that became the opportunity for other Douche bags on the Internet to try and
bring up some male female point,
you know,
to literally try to wedge
they're fucking Goddamn agenda.
So we're literally talking about a guy who,
if they're say,
and what he did,
if he did what they say what he did,
this guy is a fucking monster.
This is about getting this fucking guy off of the Goddamn street before we can
do this to somebody else.
But these selfish fucking assholes on the Internet.
Nah,
Nah.
We're gonna notice when he screams and yells and that reporter,
she just sat there.
So stoically so defintely feel privacy.
That's what they teach you.
They teach you that in journalism class.
What do you think a guy would have stood up and fought him?
So then all these women pile on and they start telling these stories of sitting
quietly as their boyfriend punched the wall right next to their head.
These selfish fucking assholes took this moment in time,
uh,
a pedophile on alleged pedophile,
freaking the fuck out and all those victims,
fuck all of them.
It's about you and whatever fucking went down during your fucking relationship
and how you are a total fucking victim.
You know what?
I got one thing to say to you guys,
ladies.
All right,
well we'll,
we'll fucking get to you on this one.
This is about the women who actually were fucking a victim of this guy.
Stop trying to fucking,
you know,
you know what it's like.
It's like back in the day,
whenever I see stuff about hair metal bands in the,
in the 80s on the sunset strip,
and you'd go up and you'd staple your fucking banner,
your little flyer up to a telephone pole,
and then two seconds later somebody else would staple.
There's over yours.
That's what the fuck is going on.
It even happens on shit like this.
It's so God damn shameless.
You know
it ladies,
you got to ask yourself something.
All right.
If more than one time a man in your life punches a hole in a wall right near
your head,
at any point,
is there any sort of self reflection where you're like,
why do I keep picking this guy?
Or what exactly is it that I'm saying to the opposite sex that is causing this
behavior?
Speaking from experience.
You know,
I remember when I got to my mid thirties and I was like,
dude,
chicks a fucking,
they're all fucking Psychos,
you know?
And by then I was just like,
wait a minute,
but what are you doing?
What are you doing?
You know?
And I actually turned around and I looked at myself and I said,
oh,
this is what I'm doing.
You know?
And then I,
I decided to stop,
you know,
fishing in the same area,
pulling out the same God damn fish.
Right.
I blamed the victim in all of that.
Yeah.
It's all you women out there who you know,
shaking the plaster out your hair,
you know,
every once in a while,
every once in awhile it might be you.
I'm just saying like,
just say one out of 3 million times when someone punches a wall near your head,
maybe you shouldn't bring up things about his family or whatever the fuck it is
that you said,
uh,
blows other times,
you know,
the guys who are aggressive and they shouldn't do that.
And um,
you know,
maybe they wouldn't be so many home depots out there if there weren't so many
guys with misdirected anger,
punching holes right next to their girlfriends heads.
A R Kelly,
could you,
uh,
just shut up for a second with your pedophilia.
This woman here has some plaster in her hair and she would like to,
uh,
tell her story while this is going down,
if you don't mind.
Um,
alright,
plowing ahead here.
So,
uh,
oh,
you know what,
I got into the premier league a little bit,
cause I know Liverpool was up by one point.
And from what I heard,
by the time we get to Manchester,
man city was up by one point.
So
let's see.
Premiere league standings.
Oh,
and everybody's trying to explain offsides to me.
And all they can say is the reason why they have offsides is so people won't
hang down at the other end of the net.
And other end of the pitch,
it's like,
well,
why don't you just have a blue line like hockey?
All right.
And then nobody can hang down by the other goal and then on.
And then if somebody bringing it down the fucking field and they're faster than
the defensive line,
they get past.
I mean,
you have what's known in hockey as a break away.
The crowd gets on its feet and that's exciting.
Hey Scott,
Jesus fucking Christ,
he scored,
don't understand it.
I understand the not hanging thing.
Oh Man.
City up by one fucking point.
All right.
And I,
I realized that somebody told me I was wrong,
that uh,
they don't have Saudi Arabia and money behind them.
Uh,
they have,
uh,
Abu Dhabi,
Baba,
booey,
um,
they have that money behind him.
All right.
What's going on?
What's,
who's,
who's playing less?
Just city is playing.
Who gives a fleas a bunch of fucking teams that aren't in it anymore.
I don't care about any of these fucking teams.
When his Liverpool,
well man city play in next.
That's,
that's the two.
You got to get into all you fucking yanks,
fellow yanks,
solicitor to this shit slide in now at the end of the goddamn season and there's
like 10 games left.
So,
you know,
if you watch all 10 Liverpool Games,
you probably see about nine goals.
So buckle up for that excitement.
Offsides no,
it's not that bad.
I'm kidding.
Alright.
Um,
what am I up to here?
By the way,
fucking jet lag to shit.
I had a great flight back.
I started to watch black Klansman and,
uh,
before the jetlag got to me and I really enjoyed that movie.
MMM.
Adam driver.
And uh,
I don't know the names of the other in the fuck.
I'm not good with names.
Um,
but I liked what everybody was doing in that movie.
I liked the guy playing David Duke.
Um,
can I see anything else than I watch anything else?
I don't think I did.
Oh,
you know what I watched,
I was really disappointed.
I Some I went on kids' TV.
Um,
I clicked that by accident and I s you know,
they had all the dumb fucking kid movies,
but then they had like three episodes of the Jetsons,
which was just the Flintstones,
which was just the honeymooners.
Alright,
so they add the Jetsons.
You don't meet George Jetson [inaudible] at that bar at the Buddha,
the Buddha batterram Italy do his,
his boy l ride.
Then it's daughter Judy and they played it.
Why,
why blah blah,
blah,
boring.
Like she's already blowing somebody.
Then Jane,
his wife,
Baba Baba,
Baba Mama,
you know,
he goes to hand her money and she grabs the whole wallet,
goes to the shopping center,
Duh Duh.
[inaudible]
Bing Bong boom.
Right.
I watched it.
That fucking show sucked.
We used the episode.
I saw.
It's like they were,
they weren't even trying,
just kind of went further and further down here.
The honeymooners was at like the highest level of funny.
And then the Flintstones,
they got halfway up the hill and then if fucking Jetsons didn't even get out of
it was so bad.
I didn't even watch the other ones.
It's like I used to watch this shit.
But what I will say about the Jetsons is how much shit they got right about the
future.
They have video phones,
they had flat screen TVs,
they had robots in the fucking house talking to people,
right?
The only thing they got wrong was the,
uh,
the workweek.
They thought with all the technology,
we were going to be working less.
And that was one of George Jetson's famous comedy lines,
big,
Oh God,
these,
these three day work weeks or murder,
you know,
flying cars,
they got that wrong.
That hasn't happened yet.
But,
uh,
most of the technology is a,
is right out there.
It's right up there,
you know,
and in the future,
women are still spending their guys money.
Like,
you know,
like there's no tomorrow.
I mean,
some things never change.
Um,
all right.
So anyways,
the big thing is tomorrow I gotta go to the gym.
I've got to get back into the fucking gym because right now there's this big
temptation where it's okay,
the big two things that I was shooting.
All right,
my acting Gig at,
uh,
one day at a time or as the world turns,
General Hospital,
whatever the fuck I did one of those soap operas that's over.
And then I did my standup special and that's over.
And I have no TV,
no television,
no nothing coming up.
This is one of these times where you put on like 10 pounds,
right?
He'd go down to the local fucking bar,
you get yourself some wings,
you have a couple of fucking peers,
you know,
and you look at the bears.
I go,
wow,
that thing looks lonely about a cup of little shorties next to it.
Right?
And next thing you know,
you're a fat fuck going.
Why did I do that?
So,
mmm,
as I told you,
I'm not drinking this year,
taking the fucking year up and a,
I'm getting the booze out of my house except for the pappies and uh,
I'm just not going to have it in my house anymore.
And then basically for the rest of my life,
if I want to go out fucking drinking,
I will,
I'll go out and do it.
But just the amount of nights that when I come home,
the fact that I won't have it in my house,
it's perfect.
I've kind of,
that I figured out that's the kind of booze hound I am.
It's like boost to me is like I half a gallon of ice cream in the freezer.
If it's there,
I'm going to fucking eat it.
All right.
The booze is there.
I'm going to fucking drink it and uh,
and I like getting fucked up so I can't have it around.
That's basically it.
Just literally talking about it makes me want to do it now.
You know,
come on bill,
your arm did.
Um,
no,
I can't do that.
That's fucking stupid.
All right.
Not Living for myself anymore.
That's what you learn,
right?
That's what the fuck.
That's what you learn when you have a kid.
If you're doing it the right way,
you're not living for yourself anymore.
Stupid.
All right.
Put down the doughnuts.
Get rid of the cigars.
You don't,
now I understand.
You know,
like when you look at your parents like why are they so goddamn boring?
Why do they just pick this regular fucking car?
Why didn't they get a cool car?
Why didn't they do any of this fucking shit?
And it's like,
oh,
because they were awesome.
Selfless fucking people.
That's why.
Okay.
And they made money and they wanted to have some leftover to,
to fucking give you when they died as the pope's to going out and buying a bunch
of Nice Shit for themselves.
Okay.
Somewhere along the line I picked that was lost in today's America.
Yeah.
It really is like,
just the level,
the level of fashion that is fucking out there now
is insane.
They used,
I mean they used to be,
it was like fucking Andy Warhol and all the skinny doses that hung around with
them were into fashion and a couple of movie stars and whatever.
And that was fucking it.
You know,
housewives,
they were into fashion.
But Jesus Christ,
I mean,
if they got something that Mrs Roper was wearing,
they w you know,
once every three years they were happy.
It wasn't this fucking shit show.
You know nowadays with like Instagram and fucking all of these social media just
bombarding
like
everybody guys too now
like the level with which that men give a fuck about what they look like in the
shit that they're wearing.
It's like they've become,
we become like women.
I don't know.
People with fucking sneaker collections
do.
When I was growing up you had,
you had a pair of sneakers.
That was it.
Like everybody had one pair of fucking sneakers.
I don't give a shit what sport you are playing yet.
That was it.
You put on your chuck Taylors and you went out and you played it.
These are my cross trainers.
What are we playing?
I have to go inside and get my soccer shoes.
Like that shit did not fucking exist and you know,
you fucking know good and God damn well a lot of his bullshit other than like
running,
I don't know,
maybe they just got better at it.
I have no fucking idea.
You know all these different kinds of genes,
all these different cuts.
There was basically when I was growing up,
there was Levi's and whatever,
people who couldn't afford Levi's war,
which was wrangler.
It was tough skins.
And then I remember the gap.
The gap had jeans for awhile.
Um,
but like the top of the line was fucking Levi's.
Oh Lee.
There was Levi's Lee Wrangler Toughskins and remember the gap that was basically
it that made fucking cheap jeans and corduroys now was it,
you got two,
three fucking pairs and you were good
and you're warm until you had fucking,
until you,
you,
you made the holes in them and then that was it.
And then eventually you fucking passed him on your mother put patches on them
and pass them down to the next fucking kid.
That was it.
I look at some of the fucking childhoods,
photos of me and the way the kids address,
we looked like we should have been hanging out with Tom Sawyer and huck Finn.
People would like patches on,
on elbows of,
of,
of their shirts and all of this shit.
And it wasn't like people were broke back then.
They just,
I don't know.
There was no Amazon there.
Like when I go down that fucking store,
driving all the way out to the Goddamn Mall,
give me a patch.
He'll just iron the sauna.
Right?
Get outside
fucking animal.
And that's the way I was and an 18 Chevrolets.
Wow.
Um,
all right.
I'm totally,
I don't know what's going on in football.
Not Football,
sorry.
And uh,
in basketball or hockey.
But I aims to sit down tonight and watch myself a couple of games so I can get
reacclimated into the greatest country that ever were there ever was that ever
will be the United States of America
and all you haters out there around the world,
you know,
with your fucking cultures and your music and your way of dressing and you find
facial hair,
you guys can all fucking ate a dick.
All right.
You're just mad because he ain't got up my blue jeans,
my fishing pole,
my fucking four wheeler and that Bass I caught 20 minutes ago.
Uh,
all right,
butcher box,
everybody.
This much month.
Butcher box is offering finely ground beef that's clean and delicious and is
taken from the most flavorful sections of the animal.
The beef consists of trimmings from the and chuck,
which makes it so versatile.
It cooks so it cooks fast,
so it's perfect for quick weeknight dinners.
Right now,
new members,
we'll get two pounds of this delicious ground beef for free and every box for
the life of your subscription.
What
this was butcher box's most popular offer last year and they're bringing it back
for a limited time.
Only way you get two pounds of ground beef for free in every box for the life of
your subscription.
Wow.
Okay.
Cook with peace.
The peace of mind knowing you're eating healthy,
high quality meat.
Each box comes with at least eight to 11 pounds of meat,
which is enough for 24 individuals sized meals.
Unless you're a tub of shit or glutinous or have some eating disorder and you're
going to just fucking blow through all of it.
But you know,
if you got your shit together when it comes to food,
I'm not saying you're not punching the wall next to your girlfriends had.
All right.
Uh,
you can choose from five different box types.
All beef,
beef and chicken,
beef and pork mixed box.
Custom box lets you choose your own cut.
Uh,
my favorite cut of meal is there.
Their heritage breed pork is the greatest thing I've ever had for $20 off your
first box and two pads of free ground beef in every box for the laugh of your
subscription,
go to butcher box.com/burr or enter
the Promo Code Burr B u double r.
That's butcher box.com/burr or enter the Promo Code Burp.
Praise Jesus.
All right,
uh,
simply safe.
Jesus Christ.
I get enough fucking reads this.
Week
four reads all my good
deep breath.
Here we go.
Simply safe.
Here's something interesting study.
Show that security systems deter burglars.
It's a fact is an asterick right next to its effect.
And I can't see where I read the footnote.
Um,
but there's still a burglary every eight seconds in America.
How well,
think about it.
I don't want to think about it to explain it to me in the coffee.
I didn't come here to think,
came here to listen and buy shit.
All right,
well think about it.
Do Burglars give up just because some houses have security systems?
You know what?
I don't know.
I haven't really,
I can't remember the last time I talked to somebody who openly admitted that
there were a burglar.
Well,
fortunately they did the research.
Of course not.
They just find a house that isn't protected.
That's why securing your home is truly an necessity.
So let me recommend this brilliant security system built by my friends,
evidently at simply safe,
simply safe beliefs.
Fear has no place in a place like home.
So they made their system ridiculously smart.
Simply safe sensors will protect every point of access to your home doors,
windows,
garage,
you name it.
Um,
if a burglar even tries to break in and ear shattering,
we'll let them know the police are already on their way.
Best of all simply saves.
24.
Seven monitoring is just 1499 a month and they'll never lock you in a longterm
contract.
More than 3 million people already know.
It feels good to fear less with simply safe.
So go with the only home security,
uh,
that you can trust.
Simply safe by going to simply save bird.com.
Go today and get free shipping and a 60 day money back guaranteed.
That's simply save bird.com comp for the home security you can trust simply safe
bird.com.
All right,
Robin Hood everybody.
Yeah.
Oh,
the old green cut.
They're robbing the rich given to the poor.
He just wants to bang your wife.
All right.
Robin Hood is an investment.
Is is an investing app that lets you buy and sell stocks,
ETFs,
options in Cryptos all commission free.
They strive to make financial services work for everyone,
not just the wealthy non-intimidating way for the Stock Market for stock market
newcomers to invest for the first time with true confidence.
Simply simple and intuitive.
Clear design with data presented in an easy to digest way.
Other brokerages charge up to $10 for every trade,
but Robin Hood doesn't charge commission fees,
trade stocks and keep all your profits.
Design slash ease of use.
Easy to understand charts and market data plus a trade in just four taps plus a
trade and just four taps on your smartphone.
Robin Hood Web Platform also lets you view stock collections,
100 most popular sectors like entertainment and social media and curated
categories like female CEOs.
Ugh.
Why would you pick a company just because of that?
This world has gone crazy.
How about a fucking eh CEO's who know what they're doing?
Who happened to be females?
Can you start that way?
Jesus Christ anyways,
and analyst's ratings of buy slash hold slash sell for every stock.
Learn how to invest as you build your portfolio.
Discover new stocks and track favorite companies with personalized news feeds.
Custom notifications for price movements so you never miss the right movement.
The moment to invest Robinhood is giving listeners a free stock like apple,
Ford,
or sprint to help build your portfolio.
Sign
up@billbirddotrobinhood.com.
That's
Bill Burr Dot Robin,
hood.com
Oh,
here we go.
And lastly,
but not least,
sleep.
Bateau doot,
doot,
Mian Ds me undies,
picking us CEO,
dude,
me undies.
She's got a Twat.
Here we go.
Stick a at the head.
Who gives a fuck?
She's got some tits.
Were being progressive.
What happened to our next quarter profits?
We should have
done a background shirt,
shirt,
a background,
background check.
She really fucking sucks.
All right,
me undies.
Ask yourself this one very important question.
Um,
is your underwear and making you happy at this very moment?
Mine isn't.
It's not making me sad either.
It's just sort of fucking,
that wasn't really thinking about it.
Now I'm in my head,
right anyways,
or are we not thinking about your underwear?
I was not me on days.
This is getting exciting.
It's like,
it's like they're reading my thoughts.
Wouldn't you like to be wearing underwear that is so soft that you can feel like
you're making love to an actual cloud all day long?
Well,
what can I just be laying on the cloud?
We have to be fucking it.
Uh,
well I've got one word for you.
Me undies.
Buzzfeed said this about me undies.
They feel like actual heaven against your skin.
Woo.
The fuck is buzzfeed.
And when did they go to heaven?
We're going to assume heaven is really soft in this context.
As men said,
they feel like silk drenched in hand.
Lotion.
These undies are so soft,
they make Bob Ross's voice.
Sound like Gilbert Godfrey,
Godfrey taken a little fucking smack there.
They're so soft.
They think that Kenny g thinks about them to get inspired to write his next
songs.
Or I thought you'd say they're so soft.
They think Kenny g needs to be stopped with his devil music.
Uh,
me undies used the coveted micro modal modal fabric,
which is a full three times softer than cotton.
Take that big cotton you puffy.
Cons.
Not only will you feel your loins are being hugged by joy itself,
but me undies gives you multiple style options for both men and women.
Choose between classic colors too adventurous,
prince,
prince like significant others,
plant babies and shamrocks me undies as a great offer for my listeners.
For any first time purchase when you purchasers,
when you go to me undies,
you get 15% off and free shipping.
That's a no brainer.
Get 15% off a off a pair of the most comfortable undies you'll ever put on to
get your 15% off your first pair,
free shipping and 100% satisfaction.
Fucking guaranteed.
Go to me
undies.com/burr.
That's me,
undies.com/ [inaudible] all right,
so when you're jet lagged and you're over there in Europe,
um,
what ends up happening is just shit starts popping into your head.
MMM.
And I don't know what.
Then you look it up and you're like,
my God,
I haven't thought about this in years.
And,
uh,
one of the things that popped in my head,
don't ask me why was that song by Doctor Hook sharing the night together.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
That's just one of the great fucking easy listening fucking songs of all time
and it gets a bad rep.
You have to understand this is post Vietnam war post JFK getting assassinated,
post Bobby Kennedy posts.
Fucking the bad acid at fucking Woodstock post all of that shit.
the 60s was a rough one.
You know,
people just wanted to listen to shit and not have to fucking think.
Alright.
Which brought you music like this doctor Hook sharing the night together.
You got to listen to,
I'll post the video.
Uh,
but here are the lyrics.
She look and kind of lonely girl.
Would you lock someone new to talk to you?
I,
yeah,
our ride.
I swear to God he says that I'm feeling kind of lonely too.
And if you don't mind,
can I sit right down here besides you?
I,
yeah.
Ah,
right.
I swear to God,
this sounds like,
um,
if this sounds like I'm making fun of a song,
but this is how it goes.
Um,
so it says,
you know,
if I seem to come on too strong,
I hope that you will understand.
I say these things because I'd like to know if you're as lonely as I am and if
you'd mind sharing the night together,
we'll Hoho yeah.
Sharing the Nad to gather.
Whoa,
whoa.
Yeah.
Right.
Sharing the night together and later on he said,
we can bring in the morning girl if you want to go that far.
And if tomorrow finds us together right here the way we are,
would you mind basically,
hey,
you know,
I'll f we can fuck if you want or I can just stand here and talk to you for the
rest of the time.
Look it up,
Doctor Hook Sharon and I had together.
We'll hoo.
Yeah.
Which then of course led me to Dr Hooks.
Sexy eyes.
Okay.
I was torturing Nia with this Sharon the night,
but then she actually,
she liked sexy eyes.
Um,
I don't know why I'm talking about this shit.
Oh,
I'm,
how much time have I done?
Have I have,
I have,
I done my contractually obligated.
30 minutes here.
Have I spent my 30 minutes with you guys?
Um,
all right.
So what did we learn on this little podcast thing here?
Um,
don't punch a hole in the wall next to your girlfriend's head,
because if you do,
she'll bring that story up while we're trying to catch a pedophile.
That's,
you know,
something that should be,
it's entirely own fucking,
you know,
I don't know.
You don't need to,
I think,
I think guys need to start having,
you're not,
not that.
Not that we don't bitch and we,
we fucking listen to me.
Jesus Christ.
I'd bitch at him twice as much as any woman does,
but it's not organized.
We need organized complaining,
like,
you know,
just to balance this out.
So the next time,
you know,
you see a woman doing something in the middle of a fucking important story,
you can insert your agenda into it.
And then if somebody comments on it in the wrong way,
there's then a big fucking fall out and then some woman loses her job.
You've got to fight fire with fire here.
What'd you like to dance with me and hold me?
You know I want to be holding you.
Ah,
yeah.
Ah Right.
You guys don't,
am I allowed to play just like a second of that.
I'll play just a second of it.
Let's see what happens.
The worst thing I do is I is,
I put money in doctor hooks.
Fucking hands.
I don't give a shit.
I like these guys.
All right.
This is the oldest song is there's like no advertising before it
[inaudible]
all your thoughts disappear.
Someone
new.
It's my favorite thing ever.
Ah,
yeah.
Oh right.
Yeah.
Try that tonight.
Bella's as your opening line.
Just walk up to a woman and start singing to it.
Sing that fucking song.
Like when Tom Cruise sang that fucking song and top gun,
right?
Just walk up to some woman,
some poor fucking woman,
just trying to enjoy your goddamn day.
Right?
So He'd probably just,
you know,
punch some fucking wall near right.
And she's just going out there.
Right?
She cut his dick off or something.
Whatever the fuck she did.
She's just sitting there.
It's probably still in her purse.
She's trying to enjoy the drink.
I just come up to her,
tap her on the shoulder.
Yeah.
Just be like you're looking cat alone liquor.
Would you Laksa won't talk to when she,
right is she gives you the look like what the fuck he get to be like.
Ah,
yeah.
Oh right.
Yeah.
Oh we can fucking go home,
man.
Fuck all.
We could just stay at here but talk for awhile.
Ah,
yeah.
Oh right.
That was the 70s,
man.
You just parted your hair down the middle and you feathered it.
You grew up fucking beard.
That was it.
You just came up with your pube saying it out every which way can you just
fucking said Shit.
As long as you tagged it with a yeah,
right.
I guess you were in.
All right.
That's the podcast.
Everybody,
um,
thank you to everyone who came out to the tour over the last year or so,
and thank you to everyone who came out.
I feel unbelievable about what we taped and,
um,
I think it might be my best one.
That's what it feels like.
And,
uh,
I still can't believe that I got to perform at Royal Albert Hall.
It was crazy.
And the fact that I now have documented it in a special that's going to be
coming out on Netflix,
maybe the summertime,
I don't fucking know.
I am so excited about that.
I can't even begin to tell you.
And the fact that I went to,
like,
I added Liverpool this time,
I had a great time.
So the next time I come out to the UK,
Ireland and all that shit,
right,
I'm going to do that,
run through Ireland,
go up to Northern Ireland and then go right down through Scotland and just,
just do a bunch of fucking cities and uh,
and ended up in London again and I got to tell you something.
I don't know what happened this trip.
I've always been a Paris guy at some point.
I don't know.
I'm starting to become a London guy.
I Dunno what happened.
I'll tell you right now.
It's certainly not the fucking food,
but just the vibe of that city.
I really like,
I was still always love Paris,
you know?
But,
uh,
I don't know.
The last couple of times I went there,
plus I've got to get back there.
I've never been to Wimbledon.
That's the last tennis major I need to see life seen.
A couple of US opens to French's in one fucking Australian and I've never been
to the,
the greatest one,
the one on the grass to grass fucking court breakfast at Wimbledon with Dick
Enberg rest his soul when I was growing up and I used to watch Bjorn Borg verse
John Mcenroe and then Mac was the guy and then,
uh,
what's his face came through there?
Boris Becker,
right?
The redheaded German guy.
I'm like,
oh my God.
There's another one out there,
right.
He came in 17 years old.
One didn't fucking 85.
And Yvonne,
Linda was always there looking like a fucking giant.
Uh,
I know he always looked more like a rock star to me.
Like that guy who was saying that,
talk about pop music,
pop,
pop music,
man,
that Guy London salt,
they had fuckheads update everybody talking about pop music.
You look go,
he was new wave.
He looked like a new wave singer to me,
and then there was going east,
east and he eats he vich or whatever it was.
That other guy,
Jim Courier,
who kind of looked like Phil Sims,
his younger brother can't believe I remember all these guys,
right.
And right as I was getting used to all of them,
then all of a sudden came fucking,
uh,
what's his face from Vegas rule?
One of the best books I ever saw open ever read,
fuck is his name.
You named,
he married a Steffi Graf.
He had to shave his head,
like make,
yeah,
and now he just has a beard.
Anyway,
I,
what the fuck's his name?
The fuck is his name.
I saw him play
whatever and then fucking a peach.
Sanford's then I started doing comedy right around then what the fuck is that
guy's name?
He used to do the fucking commercials being a rebel.
This is going to torture me
second.
I,
there's,
you can't,
I can't,
this,
these,
one of the only fucking people that went on all four surfaces.
I gotta look it up and there's no fucking way I'm closing this fucking podcast
not knowing who that guy's name is.
Tennis Book.
Open.
Boom.
What do you mean I'm not connected to the Internet?
I'm always connected to the Internet.
God dammit.
Come on.
He didn't even want to fucking play.
Oh fuck you open.
And Andre Argosy.
Jesus Christ.
Bill.
Call yourself a sports fan.
Andre Argosy.
That's right.
And then I don't know where it went.
Then the next light guy who came along,
there was that guy who he looked like a,
the guy from dude,
where's my car?
Who did punked and married Demi Moore.
Ashton Kutcher.
There was a tennis player that looked like him.
And then there was the Croatian dude who just,
he just won the French,
didn't he?
I can't fucking remember.
I don't,
I don't pretend to understand shit.
All right.
You know,
I could have just ended on how site that was about my special rather than than
fucking talking about tennis.
But you know,
isn't that the charm of this podcast?
All right.
I hope I got you through your workout or whatever the fuck it is.
You did.
Are you a little plane ride or you ride home?
Huh?
He almost home.
Do you want me to keep talking?
Oh my God.
Can we be like podcasts,
besties.
And you just fucking talk to,
you know what?
Fuck you.
I got shit today.
I got shit to do today.
I got shit to do.
All right,
so I'm gonna sign off now.
You know what,
you know,
here's,
here's the thing.
The Andrew's going to play a little bit of fucking music here and then after the
music,
he's going to be a half hour of greatest hits from a Thursday afternoon,
just before Friday,
Monday morning podcast from a Thursday.
I don't know,
a year ago,
four years ago.
I don't even know how long I've been doing these.
And uh,
that'll fill up your hour.
All right?
So that's it.
Okay.
God bless all yet.
Have a great weekend and I'll see you in
[inaudible].
[inaudible] sit down.
[inaudible]
am
Shannon.
Dot.
[inaudible]
Hey,
what's going on?
It's built bar and it's the Monday morning podcast for Monday,
March 7th,
2011 there.
I set it right.
2011,
2011.
Um,
I'm down here in Miami,
Miami beach.
I did the South beach comedy festival or this,
this,
uh,
this past Friday night.
And uh,
the fuck did I do,
I worked at the new symphony theater and uh,
it was funny.
I worked there Friday night and Thursday night,
the first comedian ever to perform there cause it's basically designed for a
symphony was a Kathleen Madigan.
So they had an all red head weekend,
which I thought was nice,
you know,
for once they paid attention to one of the,
uh,
overlooked minorities out there,
you know,
how come we don't get a day on the calendar?
What about us?
Persecuted by the Sun.
Do you know what it's like to be persecuted from Sunup to sundown?
I don't think you do.
Oh,
you fucking bitch.
And people from other Goddamn fucking groups.
I've had it.
Um,
anyways,
yeah,
down here on Miami beach and everyone is dressed like a hooker.
You know,
this is really just a,
it's a bunch of,
I don't know,
really good looking women who are dressed as fucking trashy as you possibly can.
None of them do.
You look at like,
God,
I could marry that girl.
You just look at all of them and you just start thinking about porno.
Um,
I don't get it.
It's that up and I can't just say that it's c a Miami beach area because I've
kind of seen that in like a number of different cities.
It's that,
that Kim Kardashians,
Paris Hilton influence where I don't know,
I don't know what happened abroad.
I don't know how they went from the 1950s to early sixties,
which I think was the high point of Cla,
at least classy looking women.
God knows there was plenty of gold digging whores back then.
But that whole era there,
man,
the way they dressed telling you they look classy,
your approach to them was different.
Down here it's just,
it's fucking ridiculous.
I'm sitting there with my lady,
I'm trying to pay attention to her as she's talking to me and these two checks
at the fucking next table.
Just go sit in there with a ted still like they're almost,
they were as close to being out of her dress as humanly fucking possible,
you know?
So that's what am I thinking?
Am I looking at her like,
oh,
look at that beautiful,
beautiful woman.
I'm not,
I'm thinking,
what would it be like if I just stuck my Dick Right in the cleavage as my end in
my girl's voice just fades off in the back.
I'd had [inaudible] and you attack.
Maybe you are where you get a jet ski.
I can't fucking hear what she's saying.
Um,
yeah,
it's,
uh,
I've had it,
I've had enough down here.
I am.
I'm fucking done with it.
I'm not going in the ocean.
I respect the ocean.
All right.
There's sharks in there is Barracuda.
There's jellyfish to goddamn ocean itself can just get mad at you and drag you
out to fucking see when it feels like it.
And then you're supposed to remain calm.
And just sort of,
oh,
which way is it dragging me?
I guess I'll swim sideways.
I think that's what I'll do,
you know,
is the ocean just fucking attacks you,
pulls your bathing suit off,
you know,
if you survive,
you're going to be walking up there with the Sun Burn Dick.
Is that what you want?
I doesn't know what I want.
So what I'm looking for in a vacation.
All right.
These fucking ladies down here,
they're ridiculous.
And I've been making fun of him all week and uh,
every broad I've been around a,
yeah.
I don't know that they are,
or people from Miami,
they try to defend them or you do you though he don't understand on hits Miami,
the weather,
it's just,
we are used to walking around with,
let's shut the fuck up.
Walking around less clothes.
All right.
Heavy it tits.
Hanging out of your fucking shirt and having a shirt design to show as much of
your teddy as humanly fucking possible.
That's a different thing.
All right.
That's not all.
My God,
it's so fucking hot out.
You know,
I saw it.
Right.
You know,
it was funny.
It was late at night and one of these,
these hooker dressed women who wasn't a hooker,
was walking by herself on the other side of the street.
And I said to the guy,
go look at that.
Right there I go,
that's your daughter that your daughter walking down the street.
What are you going to say to her?
And he just started laughing,
shaking his head.
It's like,
exactly.
She looks like a fucking streetwalker and now she's away from the guard down.
Hurt.
Well,
what do,
what are you going to say to her
fucking five inch fucking heat every goddamn one of them.
How much?
How much for a fucking blow job?
Um,
yeah,
that,
that really is Miami beach.
So if you want to come down,
if you want to come down here and you want to bang a 10,
uh,
I think it's almost impossible not to because if you hook up with anything down
here,
they're absolutely fucking gorgeous and they're dress like absolute fucking
hookers.
Um,
I think I saw maybe two or three class acts the entire time I was down here.
So,
um,
it was going to be great as the amount of people who are gonna fuck it,
email me and they going to try to defend.
MMM.
What is going on down here?
All right.
And all you females from Miami who going to defend this type of shit?
Let me ask you this.
If you saver,
if you savor not,
you saved your fucking savior.
Jesus h Christ showed up.
Okay.
And he was at one of those apps to parties.
All of a sudden,
you know,
he finally comes back and proves assholes like me.
Wrong.
There he is.
Jay Star,
you know on the one and two with the fucking head set on right up there.
Fucking all of a sudden starts re remix in
[inaudible] Christ
has died for rose.
Yeah.
And has risen from the dead.
The Jesus.
Um,
all right.
And he comes back.
I'd be aren't you?
At the very least the second you see them,
I know two things you're going to do.
Why don't you got to take off those God damn shoes.
And number two,
you're going to reach for your little granny shawl to cover your tits up.
That's what you're going to do.
I think that's what you're gonna do and you're probably going to try and stand
behind as many thick leggings,
sturdy whores as you possibly can as you text your friend Omg.
Can you please find me a pair of pants?
What would Jesus do?
Everybody.
What would he do?
I'm probably gonna get a ton of shit for trash and fucking Miami liked that like
I did from the potheads last week.
Some guy actually gave me shit cause I do that,
that voice.
Hey Man.
And he's like,
I'd never heard Eddie one shot.
You know what I'm talking about?
Go Watch that documentary on the Fillmore.
All right.
It's a fucking,
it's an impression of the hippies from Woodstock.
I realized that people don't talk like that anymore.
I'm exaggerating for comedic effect.
You fucking cunt.
I thought when you smoked weed,
everything became funny.
Why aren't you giggling right now?
Ah,
angry pothead.
And you never answered my fucking question.
None of you did.
How many weed smokers?
All right.
Who fucking,
I came here with my five.
My fucking question about mushrooms is trying to make some sort of point.
Last week you guys were all afraid of it.
Stayed away.
He changed the subject like a bunch of fucking politicians.
When's the economy going to turn around?
Governor?
You know,
I'm not teach 70 till this tub was built Bleah Out of vision.
What the fuck are you talking about?
Answer the Goddamn question.
Um,
anyway,
so I got to see all sides of this state.
I saw the who was,
I saw the,
uh,
you know,
the fist pumpers,
that really sounds fucking filthy,
doesn't it?
A whole bunch of twinkle toes down here too.
And then after I took a tour of the everglades the next day,
right?
I finally got to do that.
Went on a fan boat.
It,
uh,
I gotta admit,
man,
I was pretty fucking nervous first of all.
You know what's great is you,
you go outside of Miami and you get a half a mile out there and the drop off.
It's just like the ocean,
you know,
where you just sort of weighed out and everything's great.
You know,
what do,
what do you call one of those drop offs?
We have any oceanography.
Oceanography is listening now,
what do you call that,
where all of a sudden it goes from like,
you know,
five feet deep to like 125 feet and you just slip into that darker water and no
one ever hears from you again,
you know?
And then one day you come back up on the fucking beach
with three quarters of your body going like,
like the end of the terminator,
the first one,
you know when he crawls out after he sticks that little canister in his robot
rib cage,
you remember that?
And he just starts crawling.
Yeah,
I actually watched that movie unedited.
Fucking great film stands up.
Stands the test of time.
Um,
anyways,
what the fuck am I talking about?
Yes.
So I started the second you get outside the dropoff where it goes from almond,
Miami Bitch.
And um,
for some reason still wearing those white louvered Kanye West Grammy glasses
that he wore like five years ago.
Um,
yeah.
What's funny about him,
he broke his jaw.
Now he always looks upset.
He's got that bulldog mouth.
[inaudible] is his bottom lip sticks out a little,
little more than the upper lip.
Um,
anyways,
you go out there and it just immediately becomes,
hey,
why you want your shelf from frog legs?
Got Myself pickup truck.
It's the one out there with the steel balls hanging off of it high like my
mullet.
He liked this shit.
I'm immediately went out there.
All of a sudden there's like,
there's like signs,
billboards for like bingo parlor in this casinos.
So we go all the way out there and as we're driving they got these goddamn
canals and uh,
this,
these,
these fucking alligators
hanging out.
Not big ones,
just sorta like little,
like a little five footers,
but still five foot alligator man.
If that thing bits you,
uh,
you know,
you,
I'm sure you can maybe pull yourself away from the thing.
I don't know what,
I don't know what you door,
your one of your friends could start.
I guess you poke them in the,
I have no idea what the fuck you do to it,
but you're,
you're definitely losing your calf muscle or a chunk of your leg,
you know,
broken arm.
When they start doing that.
God Damn death roll,
they just lay in there.
I Dunno like people down here they used to him alligators and shit but like uh,
someone like me,
a Yankee from up north,
I really don't do well with reptiles.
They freaked me the fuck out.
So I know I'm on my way to the everglades.
They got all these alligators,
they have our water moccasins or cotton mouth is it called?
And I learned,
cause they,
they sit there with their mouths open when the,
when they feel like they're threatened and they have all,
it's all white inside their mouths.
It's like black mamas.
I always thought that snake was black.
It isn't.
The inside of its mouth is black.
The outside,
he's sort of a gray,
uh,
Jesus Christ.
Bill,
what does this fucking animal planet can you get to the Goddamn comedy?
Acuff go fuck yourselves.
I learned some things this week,
so we show up out there,
right?
It's me,
another comedian and both are fucking late A's and uh,
took one of those fan boats.
I'm going to give you some advice.
All right?
You can be a cheap fuck.
Okay.
And go on one of those fucking air boats.
I guess they call them and go on there with like 10,
12 other the fucking people.
Or You can shell out another 20 bucks a head and you can go on one by yourself.
I definitely suggest that one because uh,
this time of year,
the waters a little bit shallow and the other people will get bogged down with
the weight in there and we fucking blew by all of them.
And a little disappointed.
I didn't get to see too many fucking alligators.
I guess they were mating and they're shy and they're in the fucking tall grass
or some shit.
I don't know what was going on.
So for the first three quarters of it,
all I'm seeing is a bunch of goddamn birds.
All right.
Those white ones with the s the s turn fucking next.
Um,
I'm not gonna lie to you.
It was actually,
it was amazing and I was absolutely terrified than any second one of those
fucking alligators was going to come up and stay and just rip off one of my
legs.
And uh,
plus you can't believe down here the amount of misinformation on alligators.
These people were trying to tell me that those things can run 30 miles an hour.
They go,
they can't run 30 miles an hour for a long time.
And they also,
they can't,
like,
they can't run like Barry Sanders.
They could just kind of go in a straight line.
So what you do is you're supposed to serpentine,
which I don't get that.
It's like,
shouldn't you just run in a straight line and then break?
Right.
Why would you then break left and become you?
You end up back in his fucking scope,
wouldn't you?
I don't know what.
So I finally go on the fucking Internet.
I'm like,
give me a goddamn break.
Those fat fucks can run that fast and it turns out,
uh,
and sears.com how fast can they run?
Says alligators can not run at 35 miles per hour is previously as a previous
answer set.
35 miles an hour is how fast a horse runs or an Olympic speed skater.
Uh,
if they said it's faster,
it's fast at 35 miles an hour is faster than a deer.
People tend to make outrageous claims about crocodiles with no basis.
Uh,
just today I was a on an everglades tour and the guys,
the guide said they could go 35 miles an hour on land set of fast alligator Mike
go eight or nine miles per hour.
According to a study in Australia,
young crocodiles might be able to reach as fast as 10.5 miles an hour,
but only over a few yards.
And also their ambush,
they usually ambush.
People saw the,
I don't know,
they said no.
If they fucking run,
they usually just run away.
They're running back to water.
Um,
they run like fat people will you run in,
all of a sudden you lose your footing and you just do a face plant.
That's what they do.
They just try to stay up and then they do a face plant right into the fucking
water.
But once they get in the water,
you're screwed.
So I was also thinking with all these,
God damn alligator's laying around,
you know how many,
how many people get killed a year?
And evidently it's not that many.
They only have like,
they have like four or five a year.
That's it.
Four or five tests a year.
But then they had like three people died all in one fucking week or three people
down here got attacked.
Some woman joggers,
some shit.
She was jogging and she decided to fucking cool off her feet in the water.
And that was the last time you saw her.
Why the fuck would you do that?
Why would you do that?
That's why like whenever I watch like a fucking one of those horror movies from
back in the day,
that's what you're always yelling.
What you're watching it like what,
why are you going in there?
Why are you doing it like this?
The same thing if you live in Florida,
if you feed a hot fucking tough it out.
Go home and stick them in the tub.
Dangle them in that fucking water.
He'll imagine that shit.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Second you get pulled in to this,
to the moment you're underwater.
You have to think.
I,
I would think.
Well,
however long it takes the alligator to pull you from where you're seated into
the water.
What do you think that is?
Point eight seconds.
I would say for 0.4 seconds.
The first point to you like what the fuck?
Point three,
your holy shit.
Point four you have hope
maybe I can do.
Maybe I could do this.
Oh,
there's my ring.
There it is.
Hey Dude,
I'm doing my podcast.
Let me call you right back in about an hour.
All right.
Um,
bom,
Bom,
bom.
That's the only normal one I can get.
You want to hear my fucking things?
I was in such a great moment there.
Alright,
so 0.4 seconds.
You have hope like,
well,
maybe I can do,
oh no I can't.
That's 0.5 and then you just like,
I'm dead.
Point five to 0.8.
You're like,
I can't believe I'm gonna get,
I'm gonna die via alligator.
And then once you're under the water,
that's when you renew.
Renew your relationship with the Lord.
And I know what you guys are probably thinking,
you're probably thinking about bill because you don't believe in that shit.
What would you be thinking?
I would be praying to God and a second got a fucking hedge my bets.
My prayers would be hilarious.
If you do exist and you do give a fuck,
get me out of this or make it quick.
Oh my God.
How long do you think it takes?
Like how long do you think before you're dead?
Here's the thing,
just sitting there Chowan on your liver and you're going like,
ah,
okay.
For the love of God,
eat my heart so I can die.
I know it's getting really fucking more of it,
but uh,
I dunno man,
I could not get comfortable.
So we ended up going out there on the everglades.
I definitely recommend it,
although if you're going to go,
um,
try to go April and may cause the water levels come up I guess.
And then also the mosquitoes aren't that bad.
There's a little travel for you.
April or may water levels come up.
They're mating season.
Right.
I was just joking about them wanting to make the fucking tall grass and full of
shit.
Um,
go during April and may definitely get your own fucking boat.
And uh,
I would also say venture out as far as you can into the everglades.
Don't stop at the first one.
Just keep going.
Go as far as you can until you're out there with some fucking,
uh,
Seminole Indians,
you know,
and they're calling you in.
The guide says white man,
speak with forked tongue.
I think that that's the one you want to get on.
Um,
we actually,
we had just a couple of redneck dudes,
one and the redneck dude we had,
the guy's name was Regis and uh,
they had all this uh,
airboat humor,
you know,
where they would just like,
do you know if you enjoyed the tour,
get out to the left.
If he didn't get out to the wreck,
kick,
you get it.
Cause then you'd step in the water and the alligators are in there.
But seriously,
folks,
don't hang your legs off the boat at any point as we're going through here.
Uh,
those you who are wearing hats,
I suggest you take them off or turn them off backwards because if you don't lose
it,
leave known to fly off.
They go into the fan and then they laid off.
Finish well could kick kick,
kick off.
Just kidding.
Alright.
Fuck.
Seriously.
Journey Hatch,
ramp.
Um,
if you're watering.
No,
I am not part shark.
That's just my awful dentition.
John.
Just fucking with you.
Keep the fucking hands.
Legs inside of the boat at all times.
Yeah.
Oh,
this one.
An Algarian sounds like when it's trying to Mike,
they did all that shit.
It was fucking tremendous.
We saw another boat that got it got um,
it was hilarious.
This boat,
one of those boats that had too many people on it,
it actually a win a ground.
So they were just sitting out in the everglades waiting to be towed in.
So we came over to see if we could help him out.
And it was hilarious.
It was like six people all from Germany.
So they were getting the full on red neck experience.
I would love to hear the stories they're going to tell when they get back.
They just sitting there,
we pull up near like one tie.
Hello?
Yeah.
Hi.
And they had the most redneck dude ever and he was just standing there.
He had completely given up,
like there's no way you can get towed out.
And so he puts his cigarette in his mouth and he's fishing for his lighter as
he's talking to the other redneck owned.
He's like,
just God damn garbage can,
you know what they say?
Won't go chrome it.
Yeah.
And as he's saying,
but he's saying it like you're trained to look there.
If you know what this is,
lips together cause he wants to hold onto cigarettes.
So cigarettes sitting there,
flapping around as he's reaching for his lighter.
And it was amazing.
It was one of those moments as a performer,
I'm watching this guy going,
this guy doesn't even realize it,
but this guy is,
if someone could
imitate him,
they would win an Oscar with what he's doing right now.
Just sitting there.
No,
great,
well go chrome.
But that cigarette flap but not tied up,
boy,
fuck rock of Dar snikers genre
was just so God damn authentic.
And we,
I was sitting there with Nia and we both immediately just looked down at the
ground and just started cracking up at a,
not an asshole way,
not judging them.
And I looked over at Nia at one point I was like,
you know what?
I was like,
Lemmy doesn't have shit on this guy.
I'm not saying this guy's beyond Lemmy,
but these two could fucking hang out.
And they would be two peas in a pod.
Um,
speaking of which
underrated anybody see that,
that documentary on Lemmy from Motorhead?
Fucking tremendous.
Um,
I'm one of those radio motor had fans.
All I know is the ace of spades,
but,
uh,
definitely a fascinating guy.
And,
uh,
if he,
I think it's on demand this month should definitely try and check it out.
So anyway,
so we ended up going through the fucking everglades and then the end,
I know I made fun of those Fan Buckeyes,
but they're actually,
they're,
they're great dudes.
Tip Them.
Don't be a fucking asshole and a then we got off and they,
uh,
they gave us a baby alligator and they said that you get one of these,
you get one of these.
Are they ever trip?
Take it,
stick it in water.
Don't tell anybody you got it.
And uh,
when it gets too big,
you just flushed down the toilet.
Now they didn't get,
they actually,
they just let us hold one and uh,
was actually pretty cool.
I kind of,
I was terrified to do it.
Not like terrified.
I just thought it was going to fucking bite my finger off.
So,
uh,
it was weird,
the dog training that,
that I,
that I got through working with Cleo.
MMM.
I realized that when you want,
at least when you go to make a move with a dog,
if you're going to go pet a dog,
you don't,
no pun intended alligator arms,
you don't start to pet it and then go,
oh,
wait a minute,
is it going to bite me?
Because then they feel that and then that makes them feel fucked up.
MMM.
So the guy goes,
you know,
take the alligator,
grab it right here.
And before I would even think,
I just fucking made sure I had its mouth closed,
held it by its Goddamn tail.
And uh,
I got the picture taken,
but I've got to admit,
I was nervous handing it back.
You know,
like,
I think I could actually hold the most poisonous snake in the world.
If you showed me how to do it,
I think I could grab it by the back of its head,
you know?
And I wouldn't get bit,
but when I was going to get bit was the,
the letting go of it.
Like,
I don't know,
I don't get that whole,
do you like fucking throw it like hold onto the tail so it can't coil up and
then you,
you fuck.
Why am I asking you guys like your fucking snake experts?
You know what somebody is going to be,
hey,
you guys want to hear?
Yeah,
about
the uh,
so that,
I definitely recommend that.
And tonight I'm actually going to go to the,
uh,
actually this will be tomorrow night with the podcast.
I'm going to the uh,
the panthers are playing the Washington capitals going to get to see,
uh,
Alex.
Uh,
what is he the great,
is that what they call him?
Alexander the Great,
I'm going to get to watch him and his fucking nine goals this year.
The fuck are the capital's doing,
you know,
can I take,
can I turn that horse loose?
What's going on with those guys?
How about them broads?
They went
6.06 and o on their,
their uh,
their road trip one another one at home.
And last night they stole a point from the penguins.
Mother fuckers are seven Oh one one
the last eight games.
If you can't do the math,
it's fucking great.
I hope they're not peaking too early,
but all of a sudden I know we look all right with the penguins injuries.
I don't know.
Who Do you think it's going to be this year?
I think you gotta go with the fly.
Yes.
You know they were there last year.
They came.
Oh,
so fuck it close.
I think the flyers or the Goddamn team to beat,
but for some reason the penguins with all their injuries,
the filthy fucking Pittsburgh Penguins.
Um,
those sons of bitches,
they seem to be playing.
All right too.
I don't know.
It all comes down.
Can you beat him four times since in seven games?
I don't know.
I don't fucking know.
All right.
You guys want to read some on?
Want me to read it?
Some,
uh,
angry email.
An angry email from a fuckin pothead.
I'm all right.
I got one who disagrees with my view on product.
Okay,
Bill.
Dude,
you have obviously never regularly hung out with any weed smokers or smoked weed
yourself wrong on both counts right there,
sir.
I hung out with some of the biggest potheads you're ever gonna meet in your
life.
I'm talking about people who smoked every fucking day because they couldn't
deal.
Uh,
they use stuff.
They quotes like this.
Why do you get high at work?
Why do you,
why do you smoke all the time,
dude,
I like pot because it turns my world,
turns my life into a movie.
That's what this buddy of mine said.
All right.
So yes,
I have hung out with them.
He said,
you are usually on point with what you say,
but you talk like someone who was absolutely zero knowledge of weed.
I've never seen someone with that.
I've never seen all this is the guy never seen him.
Someone with that tire,
cliched pot,
smoker voice.
Obviously you haven't.
All right,
but if you watch shaggy and Scooby,
you see it right there.
They're making fun of the whole Woodstock generation.
Um,
and did I mention that early?
I can't even remember if you watched that fucking,
uh,
there's a documentary about Bill Graham and this and he's having the last night
at the Fillmore and there's an,
there's a musician.
If anybody can find the clip on Youtube,
I think they took it down.
That guy's just like,
well,
hey man,
you know,
just like,
man,
it's like,
yeah,
like fuck you and thanks for their memories man.
You know what I'm saying?
Man,
you gotta listen to the guy.
That's the guy everybody's making fun of.
All right.
That's what I'm doing.
I realized that people in 2011 don't talk that way,
sir.
So anyways,
he said,
most part smokers are like anyone else and don't sound like they have down
syndrome.
As funny as you are,
it pains me to hear you talk out your ass when usually you have good points.
Please smoke a joint and shut the hell up.
All right.
That part was funny.
Uh,
ps,
I know you're going to tell me to go fuck myself cause it's your podcast,
but I'm sure I'm not the only one who notices this about you.
Uh,
you know what,
I'm going to tell you what I'm really sick of.
I'm really sick of overly sensitive fucking pot smokers.
You know,
you guys are about to self righteous.
His fucking Jesus freaks.
I've added,
I've had it with you guys.
I've had it with your lies of how,
uh,
you know,
there's like there's no drinking and driving.
You can get pulled over for that and there's a test and there's nothing for
weed.
And then pot smokers say,
well,
you know what?
I actually think you drive better when you're high.
You know,
everything's so fucking clear.
They say dumb shit like that.
They say smoking weed is not addicting.
I just do it cause I like it.
You're all fucking full of shit.
All right.
I think weed is one of the more dangerous drugs is because everybody thinks it
isn't fucking dangerous.
And I think the danger of that drug is that [inaudible] I don't know.
It just makes you want to sit on the goddamn couch.
All right,
now kind of course someone's going to send me an email.
He smoked weed every fucking day.
And I'm a fucking the Valedictorian of my class.
Rarely.
Well,
you're a fucker exception.
All right.
You are doing damage to your brain.
You are fucking burning up your brain cells.
Why can't weed smokers admit that?
Is it because it's illegal and you want to make it legal that you can't be
honest the way a drunk like I am that alcohol fucking turn your nose into
fucking,
you'll look like WC fields.
It fucks up your liver.
It kills brain cells.
You get behind the wheel of a car and you could kill yourself or even worse.
Kill somebody else.
Why can't you guys admit that shit?
Ha Ha man.
Why can't you say that man?
I'm just fucking with you by the way.
You know what?
I can't.
I can't actually,
you can't say,
oh I'll weed smokers like that cause I only got one fucking email.
Somebody really disagreeing with me on my views on weed.
Um,
I don't know.
I don't fucking know.
You know my one thing I will,
I will,
I will stand by this cause I am just fucking around.
I do know this.
All right.
You can come home after work and have a beer,
possibly two beers,
depending on your tolerance and yet maybe you're a little buzzed.
That's it.
These motherfuckers who come home and get,
they get high,
you get high,
you,
you basically do the same as me drinking like six beers.
It'd be like me getting drunk every night.
If I drank six beers every night,
my girl would be talking to me going,
I think you need to go to some meetings,
but there's really no meetings for people who smoke weed.
Basically every fuck if you,
if you're getting high for fucking nights a week,
think about this shit.
All right?
You multiply that times 52 fucking not to freak you out,
man.
This is fucking 208 days of the year.
You're fucking high.
If I'm getting drunk two on eight times a year,
which was I at one point I think I was,
that's what I finally,
I started doing the fucking math and I was like,
I am very quietly kind of a fucking alcoholic here.
If you get drunk two times a week,
a year.
I'm really sounding like a fucking cut right now,
but I'm just,
this is just shit I worked out.
If you get drunk two times a week,
Friday,
Saturday night,
that's over a hundred days a year.
That's basically a third of the year your shit faced.
That's the only two times a fucking week.
Eight days a month,
you know?
Then you throw in a random Monday night football.
I would like another Pale Ale,
you know?
Next thing you know you had three or four walk out of the house.
You fucking feel like you're floating in your loafers,
right?
You get out there and your Toyota Camry,
you didn't hit anybody.
You go home,
you wake up the next day,
you feel like shit.
All right.
How many times you do that?
A year at least 20 right?
There's a third of the year your shit faced.
So pot smokers on the other hand,
I,
you know,
they,
they got a whole different thing like five fucking walked by a guy in a car and
he's got a bear.
I can't just come up to the window.
Amen.
Let me get,
let me get a couple of Poles off of that.
Just shotgun,
one of his bears.
Thanks Matt.
Thanks for getting me drunk.
Like pot smokers,
they do that shit all day.
Maybe because it's illegal.
I don't know what it is,
but they get fucking baked,
which is the equivalent,
I think.
I haven't like,
you know,
four,
five,
six beers.
Okay.
What I'm saying is,
is you pot smokers,
you're a lot more fucked up than you realize to get off your goddamn high horses
or is it,
you're not even on high horses.
You just trying to tone down the effects of that shit.
Isn't that what you're doing?
So they'll make it legal so you can just smoke it and not worry about it.
And not to mention how toxic fucking weed is now I remember when I was living in
New York,
there's Duke came out to music.
Yo,
I smoke this shit last night.
It's called with tardy cause Yo,
you'd be smoking that Shit.
Yo.
You just be retarded.
You'd just be sitting there.
You'd just be sitting there like this,
Yo.
And he makes his fucking face.
Like he doesn't have a thought in his goddamn head.
All right,
I'll let shit chronic,
all of that shit that just fucking burns your Goddam head up.
I don't know it,
uh,
you know,
fuck you know something.
Go fuck yourselves.
If I can sit here and admit how bad whiskey is,
and then I was sitting there like Judy Garland for a quarter of the year,
you know what I mean?
I'm not saying you should quit.
I'm not saying that you shouldn't,
did,
you know,
you shouldn't smoke more of it.
I'm just saying stop acting like you're taking fucking a Flintstone vitamins,
you know,
because if you really wanted to,
rather than smoking it,
you could turn it into a hoodie.
Okay.
All right.
The fucking declaration of independence.
Isn't that what they said?
Isn't that one of the,
the theories out there,
declaration of independence has written on hemp paper,
man.
Um,
anyways,
so someone who agrees with my views on pot,
I can I,
the amount of listeners I'm going to fucking probably lose this week
agrees with your view on pot.
Here we go.
Hey bill this morning.
Uh,
okay.
Hey bill,
this has been bothering me for a little while now and I'm not sure what to do.
I'm 19 years old.
I go to Umass Amherst,
go minutemen.
Um,
I had a guess.
One of the worst fucking names,
you know something minimum used to be like the fighters because they can be
ready in a minute,
right?
The minute men and go fight the real revolution.
And then somewhere along the line I believe hip hop and RNB turn minute men and
to people who prematurely ejaculate.
Do you like how my sentence slowed down there?
Cause there was too many words with big syllables.
Uh,
no,
I just been hitting it hard down here.
Sorry.
Um,
I had a girlfriend my first semester of college and was still in high school
when I was still in high school.
They go,
oh,
she was still in high school.
Oh wait a minute.
Sorry.
Now it's getting a little creepy.
Well,
she is senior.
Um,
we both knew that I would be going far away and we agreed we would stay
together.
However,
I guess her feelings changed and she wanted to be single.
I was devastated when she broke up with me and I've been really down because she
was the first girlfriend that I really liked.
Didn't I read this last week?
I think this happens to a lot of guys and I wasn't just trying to get laid.
I really liked this girl.
So after a few weeks I found out she was hooking up with this kid that I
consider to be a friend.
This is the exact same as last week.
I swear to God.
This is different media email though.
Uh,
because we've been hanging out over the summer and partying together.
What's fucked up about the whole situation is that this isn't the first time
I'll ever read this.
Last week didn't I?
This isn't the first time this guy has done this to me.
And at the end of my senior year,
I broke up with a different girl and this kid was hooking up with her about a
month later.
Then I answered this one.
I let that one slide again.
I didn't really give a fuck about any of his girlfriends.
Yeah,
dude,
blah,
blah.
So it was questioned as,
should I go back to this kid and uh,
tell them to stop going after my ex girlfriends?
Uh,
yeah.
Yeah,
he should.
He should.
I mean,
who gives a fuck?
He's going after you're sloppy seconds.
Just ask them that.
I thought I said this last week.
Just call them up and be like,
listen dude,
do you have an ability to get laid without fucking something that my Dick's
already been in?
All right.
Do I have to be your Dick Lewis and Clark?
The fuck is wrong with you.
Why don't you go forge some of your own stop being Coby Bryan and being Michael
Jordan stopped doing the shit that I already did and taking credit for it.
You fucking cunt.
Fuck you.
And that fucking whore that you're with right now.
Okay.
Do you realize that this keeps up?
Someday I'll be able to say,
Hey,
I fucked your wife right before you fell in love with her.
She loved it.
And the edge,
um,
just say some mean shit like that.
All right?
How the fuck was that?
Agrees with me on pot.
I am I an idiot.
All right.
Advice
built.
This is my tale of woe and in the interest of preserving the flow of the story,
I'm using names.
So I started at a Lexus dealership back in August a little bit after that.
A girl,
I don't give a fuck if you,
you know something.
I don't name names,
but if you guys are going to put names in your fucking thing,
I'm not going to say last names,
but I'm just going to name the names because my reading out loud skills are so
fucking bad.
I don't,
I don't have time to add other shit here.
All right.
So anyways,
so bill,
I started working at a Lexus dealership back in August a little bit after that.
A girl named Ashley started in the Accounting Department.
She was a cutie.
Uh,
for a few weeks.
I kept getting shit from the guys in the parts department for not going after
her.
That's hilarious.
What are they all married or the older perverts a little bit at a man who you're
not sticking your fucking Dick in a ah,
go over there.
What do you will fucking fig.
Um,
so they've given me shit for not going after,
but uh,
but I had a good reason.
She was 20 years old.
I'm 23,
so it's not overly creepy dude.
That's not even close to being creepy.
That's good that you have a conscious about that.
But think about that.
Someday when you're fucking 47,
she's going to be 44 and she's going to be up your ass telling you were and
where you can't wear your shoes in the house.
So why don't you bang her at the height of her fucking good looks.
All right.
Get that thought right out of your head.
That's my first piece of advice.
All right,
let's continue.
Uh,
right from the start.
I knew she was going to be the kind of girl that could only communicate through
her thumbs,
text messaging a and B,
too immature to handle any actual conversation.
Not to sound self righteous.
Uh,
but going after against my better judgment,
I followed my Dick's advice to started,
started to get something going after a few weeks of us chatting every once in
awhile,
I told her,
I told her I needed a massage.
A.
Okay,
dude,
that's a really creepy way to try to get her in the boat,
so to speak.
I need a massage.
All right,
well we'll deal with your opening lines later on in this.
All right.
But just put a little fucking little little check next to that to that.
That's not a,
that's a creepy way to fucking enter the atmosphere there.
All right.
Um,
anyways,
like a champ.
She tried her best to oblige,
but shit kept popping up when she walked by again.
I jokingly handed her my number telling her to call me and we'll schedule that
massage.
That's just creepy.
Massage is creepy.
That's,
that's a creepy word because creeps go to massage parlors and they have people
fucking do things to them.
That is fucking creepy.
And also a lot of perverts kind of go with the massage thing.
You're young,
you're 23.
I get it.
I had zero game at 23 beyond zero subzero freezing temperatures.
I was horrific with women at 23.
So the fact that you're even given a girl a number,
I right.
You're way beyond where the fuck I was.
Act.
I'm not talking down to you,
but she got to get the word massage out of your fucking game.
It's just a creepy fucking word.
And it creeps women out.
Um,
anyways,
the day after I wake up with a t that,
um,
after I gave the text message,
whatever,
I give them a number of the day after I wake up,
I have a text message says,
hey,
it's Ashley.
I can't help it.
So he says,
so I can't help but think.
Gotcha bitch.
That's nice.
So,
uh,
so after week of texts we get together,
she finally calls me and pretty much in fights herself over to my house.
She comes over all gussied up.
Perfect outfit,
perfect makeup,
the whole fucking package.
Uh,
we watched some TV and she comes up with the idea of bringing booze into the
situation.
Very nice.
I agree.
After a few hours or so,
she finally says,
I got to go.
She gets up to leave.
She tries to give me a high five as a goodbye.
So I come back with,
I'm more of a kiss.
Good night kind of guy.
Jesus Christ,
Dude.
All she does is laugh and start walking to her car.
I got mind fucked.
All right.
First of all,
dude,
um,
you were there for two hours and you were drinking and she's over there at some
point.
There's a moment where you got to make a move.
If you don't make a move,
then it gets weird and then they just shut down and say,
okay,
this guy is an interested,
so then she's going to leave.
Then she says,
hey,
good stuff because the I five year and then all of a sudden you try to make it
intimate in the last five seconds,
you're going to be there and you come with a more of a kiss.
Good night kind of guy.
That's just creepy,
dude.
You're creeping them out.
All right,
but I get it.
All right.
I was creeping them.
I was,
I wasn't even in the game to creep them out at that point and I went through my
phase where I was creeping them out.
I said,
dumb shit like that before too,
so don't feel embarrassed or anything.
Okay.
You're just,
you're coming with a,
you know,
it's like you're right in your first five minutes of comedy here.
You know this.
None of this shit.
This is going to be embarrassing when you get older.
All right,
here we go.
This continuous,
after another week or so,
she calls me up again and invites herself over.
Very nice.
She comes over again.
All gussied up.
We pop in waiting.
I don't even know what that is.
That's a movie.
Okay,
and she gets the booze.
A few minutes go by and she asks if I want the massage.
Very nice.
Said I never got on my stomach so quickly.
She straddles me.
It tells me to take my shirt off.
I get a good 30 minutes in and I asked if I'm doing her next dude.
Your lines that it's like blunt force trauma.
You just punching this girl right between her tits with you,
with the alliance here.
Um,
anyway,
she says,
she tells me she doesn't know.
So I tell her just to lay down while telling her can't work with shirts.
Jesus Christ.
Dude,
you can you try to finesse it a little bit?
I don't do I fi's.
I'm more about the kids.
Get your tongue out this weighty.
Oh,
you ain't leaving the house.
Are you lean it against the fucking door when you said that.
Um,
Jesus Christ.
Okay.
I say I'm not good with shirts.
Where the hell am I?
She's so she takes her shirt off and let me guess as she took her shirt off.
You didn't say anything,
you weren't touching her or anything.
You just sat there.
So it could be as awkward as humanly possible as you heard the sound of her
taking her shirt off.
Um,
is if she's just gotten arrested for drugs or something.
Uh,
she takes his shirt off and leaves on her Bra.
Of course she does,
but uh,
that quickly gets out of the picture.
Very nice.
It's fucking guys.
Oh cause she's 20.
I get it.
So her mind saying no,
but she's too embarrassed.
So she continues.
All right.
After a while she says she has to go,
but I told her,
um,
she could just sleep here.
She agreed.
So thinking I was going to get laid.
I went and I took a piss and got back to my room to find her fully clothed with
her fucking coat on in my bed.
I couldn't stop thinking,
what the fuck he goes.
I slept pretty good though.
All right.
For all you rookies out there,
uh,
there's a lot of guilt that young women have when they're,
when they're going to hook up or whatever that they're doing.
They got a lot of voices in their hand by my being a whore and that type of
thing.
So the thing is you got to keep the fucking plate spinning.
All right?
You can't leave them alone if you leave them alone for any period of time.
That gives them a chance to entertain that voice that's saying,
why am I doing this?
Do I want to do this?
I work with this guy.
We're not even going out.
You gave her time to basically do the right thing.
Um,
I don't know.
So yeah.
So yeah,
of course she come back,
she's fully fucking clothes.
It's like a,
and I don't,
I don't use the analogy now.
I'm all set.
I'm feeling like a creep now cause I'm trying to teach you how to fucking bang a
girl like this.
This whole fucking emails just really creepy,
but I'm halfway through it.
I can't stop now people.
All right,
let's go.
He says now for the good part,
uh,
December rolled around.
Okay.
Well you've really never given told me when this started.
Oh,
he said August.
That's right.
My fault.
All right.
December rolled around and there was a company Christmas party,
old Jesus at my boss's house,
which we both attended,
me and a buddy,
I'm not saying his name when,
and she immediately finds and latches onto me after a few hours and her friends
giving her a fuck load of booze to,
to suck on.
She comes up to me and asks if I want to get out of there while biting her lower
lip and other gestures to that drive me crazy.
I agree.
Then she goes out of her way to invite this,
this other dude along,
which leads us to believe that there's going to be some sort of double
penetration action.
Jesus Christ.
Now she's bringing this other guy
to fuck the whole thing up.
That's going to be like the chaperone 20 ways we choose.
This is,
this is how,
so,
uh,
you know,
the next day the phone call,
this is how all this shit goes.
Cause men and women just do not think the fucking same way,
especially at this God damn age completely not understanding what's going on
here.
Anyway,
so he said,
we choose my place for the,
for the alcohol and head out while we're walking out to the car.
She has her hands all over me.
So I'm thinking this shit is going down to this girl.
She's a Dick.
Tease man.
Jesus Christ.
We get to my place and we crack open some bear and she blatantly asked me to put
some porn on to watch.
Isn't this what happened to like that?
The,
the fucking Duke Lacrosse team?
Um,
at this point I think it's,
it's fucking over with.
I start getting all touchy feely with her and she seems a little annoyed.
Finally she starts to wrestle with me and I go in to kiss her and she dodges me
thinking she was playing.
I continued my advances.
Now there's a lot of women getting upset here.
You can't get fucking upset when she's doing that shit.
You want to come on?
Can we just hang out a little bite of the bottom lip?
Let's put a point on.
Um,
I continue my advances and then she gets genuinely offended.
Me being a little angry.
I asked the other dude to leave so we can have a little chat and I proceed to
ask her what the fuck,
what the fuck she's looking for here?
She tells me nothing and that she doesn't have any interest in me.
Fucking furious.
I just start playing a video game and drink Jameson while she continues to ask
me what's wrong.
I'd never been so close to punching a girl.
In closing,
I started sending her incredibly asshole,
his text messages.
Ah Dude,
why would you do that?
To self destruct?
Any chances of her talking to me again,
but I still left.
It still left a very conti taste in my mouth.
I'd love to hear your take on this.
All right dude.
All right.
Yeah,
she's a Dick Tease.
All right.
And um,
I,
I don't know if she's got a few
fear of being alone.
She's using you,
she's using you for company.
She's probably does now obviously it doesn't have a boyfriend,
so she needs to get rid of her little fucking sexual acts.
So she kind of takes it up to the point and then backs off from it.
But the problem is with the girl like that,
that first night she came over there,
you had the close the deal and when you didn't close the fucking deal,
that's it.
You got to fucking walk away and once you realize that girl is mind fucking you
basically being a Dick Tease,
you have to two things you have to do.
You got to walk away and two,
you can't get mad.
You have to accept that that's part of the fucking game,
but for some reason you really want to still bang this girl.
You have to realize that.
Then what you have to do is you have to start playing mind games back with her,
which personally gets fucking exhausting.
But if you want to do that in the future,
what you then do is the next day when you go to work,
this has provided you didn't get upset is when you see her,
you don't ignore her.
You're not snide to where you're not angry tour.
What you do is you like,
Hey,
are you doing big smile?
If it's acceptable,
a hug at work,
if he can do that or whatever,
you'd just beyond cool with her.
All right?
But you don't try to go out with her or anything.
And then later on that day or whenever the opportunity arises,
you compliment some other female within earshot of her.
All right?
That will cause a dick tease to be like,
wait a minute,
eh,
la La
fucking start coming your way.
And that's how you,
that's how you get them on the boat.
You gotta you gotta just turn her,
you get,
it's weird.
You've got to walk backwards.
You know what it is?
It's like,
like charged magnets.
You know what I'm saying?
If you fucking,
uh,
if you take a fucking,
I don't know what the fuck it is.
What am I trying to say?
I don't try to say,
it's like you take a step towards it,
it fucking goes off the other direction.
If you walk away,
it starts coming towards you and you just got to slowly,
okay.
Slowly back them into the boat.
But I dunno,
I dunno.
I don't know what to tell you as far as you fucking open lines of what you
really have to do,
dude,
is when you just want to fuck a girl,
you have to say,
you got to present that to them,
you know?
Um,
and the only way you got it,
you got to do it through bombing.
Okay?
You're,
you're blunt force trauma
period.
I,
I dunno,
it's,
it's impossible.
It's,
it's a,
it's like how do I learn how to do standup,
right?
Five minutes of jokes and you have to go up there.
That's all the only advice I can give you.
And you've got to go up there.
You got to fucking figure it out for yourself.
But like,
eventually you have to just,
you just want to bang a girl.
You can't,
uh,
does he,
you have the,
you have the right instincts.
You're steering the conversation towards sex,
but you're doing it at 90 miles an hour.
You're grabbing her by the back of the head and slamming her face into the wall.
You can't do that.
Uh,
you know,
I don't know.
I don't know where,
where,
where to begin.
I'm trying to think of all the fucking horrific things that I did back in the
day.
Um,
I remember one time hooking up with a girl who was like 23 or 24 when I was
about 33 or 34
and uh,
what the fuck she said at one point she got,
she came over to my apartment and I invite her in.
Right.
Cause I was a veteran at that point,
but I don't have to take it in the movie.
Why do they come on up?
Meet me over at my place.
This is embarrassing.
So she came over at one point we start fucking making out,
doing whatever and then she says,
wait a minute,
where is this going?
She hits me with that shit and I was like,
uh,
I'm like 11 years older than you.
By the time you're 30,
I'm going to be 68.
What do you mean?
Where is this going?
It's going nowhere.
You know,
this is just basically,
it's a sexual,
I'm basically going to be the reason why you're not going to have a midlife
crisis because all the fucked up shit you want to try but are too afraid to do
with the guy you're in love with.
You can just do it with me.
Obviously.
I said it a little smoother than that,
and then,
you know,
she was just like,
oh,
all right.
Oh Jesus Christ.
And then,
oh,
I can't even tell you what happened then.
And it's not sexual.
It's disgusting.
Oh God.
Now I gotta tell you this,
this is really fucked up.
This is why I'm so happy.
I've got a great girl now.
So we ended up fooling around
and,
uh,
the next morning,
wake up,
you know,
he started in the living room
and in the bedroom,
you know,
that whole thing.
You never,
you never give them a chance to reconsider.
Right.
I don't even give them the chance to fucking think about it from the living room
into the bedroom.
You don't do that.
You just constantly hands or move in.
You kiss it on the whole fucking thing.
Right.
So
she goes to,
this is,
I can't believe I'm going to tell you this.
She goes,
I walk out into the living room the next day cause she's getting dressed and
she's looking for underwear.
And she had these white lace,
like foggy kind of underwear,
not a thong.
Geez.
Not Thought.
Yeah.
And they were in a,
they were crumpled up on the floor.
All right.
If anybody gets really grossed out,
I suggest just shut it off here right now.
All right.
I looked down at them,
so proud of myself,
you know,
that I hooked up and I looked down and there was a skid mark about,
I would say at least four inches long and those white panties.
And I was like,
what was going to fucking dry heave?
I didn't go down on her,
thank God.
Um,
how else is really just coming back?
And I was just like,
I didn't know what to do cause she was like,
yeah,
well I can't find my underwear.
Ha.
So I fucking went out to look for him and then I found them.
And then it's just like,
you know,
if I had a stick in my apartment,
I would have picked him up and
handed them or,
but,
uh,
I didn't have a stick,
so I acted like I couldn't find,
I wandered over towards the kitchen and then she came walking out and she's
like,
oh,
there they are.
And I know she saw what the problem was and she tried to play it off and she
just put them on,
Ugh,
that I,
you know what,
let's have a vote.
Was that the most disgusting story I've ever told in the pie?
That was fucking errific right.
I Dunno.
W was there any advice in that?
Jesus Christ,
I don't know.
How the fuck did I relived that one?
Wow.
Um,
how about some youtube videos this week?
Somebody sent me this youtube video of this guy on,
on,
uh,
Dr Phil.
He's like a,
he has this website,
men are better
than women.com.
He's really like a cartoon chauvinists cartoon character kind of chauvinist
stick person where he's just like,
you know,
women aren't good at working.
I mean they shouldn't have,
they shouldn't be allowed to vote.
Like he does shit,
like at that level.
Um,
which is just cartoonish.
There's a couple of funny things that he says.
At one point he standing next to an ATM and he's taken cash out.
He goes,
this is how women perceive men.
This is how they look at,
right?
Which obviously not all of them do,
but it's so it's such a true fucking statement.
If he just adjusted a few words,
said,
well if he said a lot of women or there's a sizeable group of women that look at
guys like this,
you know,
and I know there's a lot of broads out there that are getting upset by this,
but you know,
you guys say the same shit,
don't you guys go on TV and the radio and what's that expression?
A good man is hard to find,
you know,
but for some reason you can't say a good woman's hard to find.
They are,
they are hard to find.
But this guy basically,
so he goes on,
Dr Phil and this lady,
this lady starts heckling him.
And I'm telling you,
when I say a classic classic comeback,
this,
the,
the comeback this guy has,
would have any respectable standup comedian on the ground laughing this,
this fucking lady,
you know,
they do the usual shit.
You know,
when they get insulted when a guy insults them,
they do,
you know,
they,
they basically,
females have like a
very,
I don't know,
for some reason they think they're very limited with their arguing ability.
Like if they get an argument with the guy,
then they're,
they're either going to attack your Dick size,
your sexuality or uh,
Oh yeah,
well,
whatever.
So that's basically what this woman does.
She goes,
you know,
I'm listening to you.
I bet you you,
you don't go out with any women.
You know,
she attacked him that way and he fucking,
he,
he brings the hammer down.
I don't condone what this guy does.
I actually think what he's doing is like a paint by numbers.
So to shock.
There it is.
I challenge anyone to have a gay or a ringtone than that.
MMM.
Anyways,
uh,
check out that youtube video and a,
we got a bunch of other funny ones where I'm actually just coming up on an hour
here.
I'm trying not to make these things too fucking long.
Let's,
let me just read a couple more advice and then a couple more.
Is it racist,
racist?
Um,
all right,
here we go.
Bill high from Australia.
Uh,
I seem to share a lot of your views and I want some advice on women.
Jesus,
this is all women's stuff.
Oh,
this week I'm supposed,
I'm only asking you because I want confirmation of my stance,
but who gives a shit?
Okay.
So generally,
uh,
so I generally look for value in things that I buy are things that I do with my
time.
I'm in my mid twenties and my parents
and my parents' friends put a lot of pressure on me to get a girlfriend.
I've had girlfriends and I always just got bored and sabotage it or fucked it up
somehow by not paying enough attention,
I pretty much decided that I want,
don't want to get married there.
Everybody calling me bom,
Bom,
bom.
Bom makes me feel important.
It feels like,
like announcement music,
like I've just walked in and people that are acknowledging,
I know.
I'm sorry.
I need to download a rig tone.
I should have the oh,
Jesus ringtone.
But I don't,
um,
anyways,
let's go back to this.
Um,
fucking sabotage shit.
To be honest,
I'd rather spend my money on myself and spend my time doing things I want to do.
Dude,
that's very,
that's very mature.
You know,
you,
all you're going to do is just end up hurting.
Somebody said,
yeah,
just bang them in and then leave that,
that hurts way less.
Especially,
especially if you're upfront.
Where does this go?
And it's going nowhere,
sweetheart.
You'll want to write it.
No,
sorry.
Um,
as far as sex goes,
it takes too long.
What?
It's always worse than you thought it would be.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
I haven't read.
I haven't read any of these,
by the way.
And you're sweating your balls off under two feet of thermal blankets.
Dude.
You know,
you have the option to not have those blankets on.
Seriously.
What the fuck is it with women and the temperature?
I digress.
Basically I find women overall to be bad value.
There's two types of men as I see it,
those interrelationships that seem to be able to tolerate,
tolerate women.
And those that women won't go out with because they're ugly or don't have enough
money.
But I don't fit into either one of those groups.
I think I'm perfectly capable of acquiring or girlfriend,
but I just can't do it.
At least I can't be bothered maintaining a relationship.
I could see myself still being single at your age and was wondering how you've
dealt with people constantly nagging you about being single.
I can't really explain
that the world is overpopulated and I'd rather watch my big TV and peace without
some little annoying prick running around because then I'm labeled as some sort
of inhumane monster.
Any advice you can offer will be much appreciated.
You don't need any advice,
dude.
You know who you are and you know what you want.
Just continued doing it.
And you have to realize that,
uh,
people look out of their own heads,
you know?
That's so they see the world,
how they see it.
And when you don't see it the way they do,
they argue it or they,
they're just confused.
Uh,
you're not hurting anybody.
You know,
there's people out there who get married because they're of a certain age,
like,
I should be getting married.
This is the age you get married.
They married somebody they're not in love with,
which is a fucking horrific thing to do to somebody a lot more.
I don't know.
There's a lot of people out there who shouldn't have kids.
They just fucking have kids and that terrible fucking parents and their selfish.
They'd rather sit around watching TV like me or go learn how to play drums like
me.
I am a selfish self centered cunt and a I w I,
you know,
I think I'd be a good dad at this point,
but um,
you know,
I was an angry fucking maniac when I was in my twenties.
You think I'm angry now?
Like this podcast would even have been funny in my twenties.
It would just be like Jesus,
dude.
Um,
you know,
when I would have brought a kid in the world then he would have been an angry
maniac.
So,
uh,
I dunno kind of bugs me that I waited this long,
but in general I'm kind of glad I did.
Um,
in,
what else?
What that,
what the fuck was I going to read?
Oh,
I know a couple of oh Jesus ones and then we're out of here.
Where the hell,
how the hell do I get to this?
Ah,
you motherfucker.
While I'm trying to get to that,
I'm coming up.
I have,
um,
I'm getting going to be at the uh,
the wise guys in Utah on uh,
March 18th and 19th.
I have all that information up on my website,
[inaudible] dot com please show up for that show as is.
It's a nice quick flight and I would like to,
I like nice quick flights.
Steven,
funny,
right?
Here we go.
Is it racist?
I haven't read this one at all.
So I have no fucking idea what this person's going to say.
So forgive me if this one,
cause the really offensive,
ignorant ones.
I just don't read because I think people are just fucking around or you're just
beyond help.
All right.
Hey,
bill loved your podcast.
Love your comedy,
uh,
yet Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
Here's what I want to ask.
If he could be racist,
right?
Deukmejian when the team warms up in the shoot around,
uh,
I guess basketball,
they basically well shoot around and there's always one or two white guys who
are not players.
The team managers or assistants who passed the balls back to the players when
they make or miss their shots.
But the white player who was suited up in uniform was standing next to the other
assistants or managers and was passing the ball out to the other black players
and he never got a chance to take a shot before the game started.
Considering every player on the team warmed up,
except for the white guy who was sitting in a lawn chair rebounding for every
other black player on the team.
Is it racist?
Keep up the great work.
Um,
no,
there's no racism going there.
He's either lazy or hurt or there's some sort of hazing going on.
He might be a rookie or a fucked up in the last game and that's his punishment.
Or maybe it was his turn.
I have no idea.
There's no racism going on there.
I don't think that they were saying,
ah,
you know,
do they have like a rally their team there and they just decided that,
uh,
that this guy could not shoot the fucking ball because he was white.
I mean,
you're really,
you're really stretching it there.
I'll tell you though.
I did go.
I did daddy tell you guys this one I went to,
uh,
when I went to fucking a,
that Portland trailblazers game when I was with Paul Versey and we put money on
the trailblazers and they will make an a comeback against New Orleans.
And they came down the court and a fast break and they ditched it over to the
white guy and he fucking,
I can't remember,
he missed a dunk or whatever.
In the second he did it,
me and Paul both looked at each other and went to fucking white guy,
fucking white guy.
Why would you get out of the game,
put on a suit and fucking,
you know,
start drawing on that,
that little fucking legal pad or whatever the fuck is she supposed to be doing,
but you know,
or stay out on the perimeter.
Don't try to take it to the fucking rack.
And if you do try to take it to the wreck,
do it.
Pau Gasol
does just start screaming like he just got raped because maybe then you can take
a couple of unguarded shots,
shots by the,
uh,
the foul line.
I'm telling you.
Watch your Lakers game anytime.
POW makes a move.
Oh,
is he goes there.
I just fucking hate that fucking money.
He's a great basketball player.
But that fucking,
what are you yelling about?
Sorry.
All right,
Bill.
Is it racist?
Um,
is it racist for me to say all Asians are racist?
Uh,
yes,
I would think so.
I'm a white guy that happens to have dated a lot of Asian women of different
backgrounds from some from Asian,
some Asian Americans,
some actually born abroad,
all of whom were explicitly racist,
mostly against other Asian ethnicities.
For example,
my Korean x hates Japanese people.
Chinese x hates Filipinos.
A Japanese x thinks the Chinese are stupid and the Thai Taiwanese are stuck up,
et cetera.
I should note that I didn't exclusively target Asian women who date.
I dated all sorts of women.
Some of them were Asian.
Uh,
my wife,
uh,
white girl thinks it's racist,
racist.
When I say that all Asians are racist.
Yeah,
well it is dude.
I mean just cause the five that you banked.
I mean,
how many,
you know,
me,
Asian women,
you would have to fucking have that experience with before you realize that now
I'm not going to sit here and try and pretend like those groups get along with
each other.
You know,
it's pretty safe to say any country that borders and other country,
they don't like them.
You know,
English England and Ireland,
England and France,
France and Germany,
Germany and everybody.
Japan,
Koreans,
Japan would,
they did the,
I mean,
first of all,
I understand if a people,
China have issues with people in Japan.
What the fuck they did during World War Two?
I read this book called the rape and Nan King.
I mean,
that alone it was,
was just fucking brutal.
So I mean,
uh,
I don't know.
Maybe,
maybe you,
I dunno.
I don't know.
Maybe you just kept,
you know,
when you keep dating women,
I,
every woman's a psycho and then he kind of figure out that you keep picking
psychos.
Did you see,
I don't know.
That's kind of,
I'm just kind of stretching it there.
How does that work?
Did you just keep
somehow picking racist Asian women?
Were you attracted to them?
And it's fucking bizarre,
but I think,
yeah,
I think it is racist to say that you can't say,
you could say every Asian woman I dated was racist.
If that's what it was.
Our,
the fuck knows.
Anyways,
hey bill as a fellow,
pasty white male dating a beautiful black woman.
I say racist shit all the time.
Really?
All right.
The n word is off limits,
but I do make fun of her for having the middle name.
Love Fonts is that I said
I also tend to react to any stories on TV shows about young black males by
saying how hard it,
how hard it did for me to live my life as a strong black man.
I see.
This is the danger of not reading these up before I considered entering the Mr.
Black San Diego contest.
That would be funny.
I guess.
Am I racist?
I'm going to end up marrying this beautiful woman.
Sorry about the comedy central show.
Not working out a few or Bubba Bubba.
Bubba.
Ah,
is it racist?
I,
I'd have to hear how you're doing it.
If you fucking around and you're being a Dick,
uh,
you could be a dick.
Yeah.
I mean,
a lot of the shit that you said now that I read it out loud on the podcast
probably would be considered racist or offensive and that type of thing.
It depends.
Is,
is your girlfriend laughing?
You know,
I mean,
I,
I believe me,
the shit that comes out of my mouth when I watch TV,
every fucking thing you could think of.
I make fun of fucking everybody.
Um,
so I,
I if you,
if you're doing that,
like my girl watches reality TV,
I fucking can't stand it.
Okay.
So I make fun of every goddamn person on it.
And she laughed.
Sometimes other times she gets annoyed.
But the reason why she's getting annoyed is because I'm disrupting the show,
not because I'm truly saying anything offensive,
but,
um,
I dunno.
I Dunno.
Is it,
is it racist that you're doing that?
I think she would say something.
You know,
I think the day she gets up and punches you in the face,
I think you're going to know or she really gets mad.
And if she really gets fucking mad,
then you have to realize that should be that you're taking it beyond the point.
Uh,
and then also just because you have a black girlfriend,
you can't use that.
It'd be like,
well,
I have a black girlfriend.
I can't be racist.
Yes you can.
Yes,
you can.
Um,
you could still be fucked up,
you know?
Right.
You can have issues,
but with other groups of people,
Jesus Christ,
I am,
I'm fucking sick of this topic.
I think this might be the last week of this fucking topic,
right?
I've had,
and you know what?
Maybe it's because I'm in a hotel room where you can't open the fucking windows
and it's 900 fucking degrees out.
You know,
why can't I open the fucking windows and get fresh air in here instead of having
to turn on the God damn air conditioner.
Why the fuck can I do that shit?
You know why?
Cause there's a bunch of sue happy fucking cops out here,
which is why he can't open the fucking windows in a hotel room.
Cause they got to worry that some Douche bag is going to get drunk and fall out
or jump out himself,
you know?
So then guys like me have to suffer.
It's the same fucking reason why you can't find a Goddamn hotel pool that's
deeper than three feet because some fucking assholes going to get drunk and
drown himself in a legitimate deep end.
Oh,
here's something I learned and I actually tweeted about it like a fucking pussy
is um,
here's one for you.
Don't judge a hotel by its lobby.
All right?
It's the same thing is when you have a piece of shit car and you want to sell
it,
see you slap some rims on it,
you know,
or a high performance fucking exhaust system.
So it sounds like it has more power than it does.
All right.
It's fucking,
yeah,
cause they,
they go all out with the lobby and then he put that shit on the website and you
think everything's fucking fine and dandy.
And then all of a sudden what happens?
You get in the God damn elevator and you step off the elevator and they have
that casino rug from fucking 1973 it looks like they sewed together like 12
Robin Williams fucking shirts.
Dude,
I have an in my hotel,
I have an old school fucking,
what do you call the old all tube?
It's not a flat screen.
It's fucking ridiculous.
The amount of money.
I'm on Miami beach and I,
and I don't want to fucking talk about it.
Whatever.
All right,
that's the podcast for this God damn week.
All right.
People stopped suing people so we can have legitimate fucking pools.
Can you scan?
You do that so you can open a hotel fucking window.
It's your fault if you fall out.
Okay.
It's your fault if your kids are moron and you're not a good parent.
If the kid crawled away from you and fell out the fucking window,
what were you doing?
Huh?
Tie him down.
That's fucking brutal.
Um,
all right,
that's the podcast for this week.
I'm going to have hide some ups,
upcoming dates here.
Uh,
I'm living,
I've never sweated during a fucking podcast before.
Suddenly ridiculously hot.
Um,
all right,
here we go.
Um,
and we at wise guys in West Valley City,
Utah,
um,
on March 18th and 19th.
Did you guys think about that?
That kid on Byu,
sorry,
I had the hiccups kid on Byu played on the basketball team and he admitted that
he had premarital sex,
knocked his girlfriend up,
said he was gonna marry her and they still kicked him off the team.
I got to go with the college on that one.
Believe it or not.
You know,
they told you what the rules were.
If you didn't like the rules,
don't go to the fucking school.
You know?
That's like if I,
if I get booked on a corporate Gig,
I know I've used this example before and they said,
we want him to work totally clean.
This is how much we're going to pay.
And I say,
okay,
and then I show up and then I start dropping f bombs.
Right?
They're fucking [inaudible].
They have the right to get mad.
Don't take the fucking Gig.
Don't go to Byu Byu.
If you want some pussy this,
they,
they make you sign a no pussy contract.
Don't sit there and act surprised and all these other fucking assholes who
aren't Mormons with 32 wide.
That's why they,
that's why they marry so many fucking women by the way.
So that they're trying to make up for those college years when they didn't get
the fuck,
you know,
and now because they're married,
they can have a fucking orgy.
Can you imagine that?
That would be,
that would probably,
do you think that would be worth it?
And I know the old joke,
Jesus Christ,
you can't put up with one woman gave love.
Welcome for,
you know,
actually the reality is she just get,
a couple of call girls and do that,
pay him and then just have them fucking leave.
Right?
That's probably what you should do.
But if you had four fucking wives,
that would be great.
You would win every argument unless they all banded together,
then you'd be in trouble.
Oh Jesus.
You could do a lot of pimp shit to start,
you know,
to gain even more control.
You could just,
you know,
the ones that are the weakest one,
you start treating her the best cause she's doing all the good shit.
Then you break down the other ones,
you know,
do you get them in line?
Then they look like once you know these proud
free mustangs running in the wind,
now they're just sitting there with their heads looking down at the carpet is
they bring you over TV dinner.
I think I'm gonna move to Utah.
Um,
I'm also going to be at the,
uh,
I'm going to be at the RECI stretchier theater.
And uh,
Maryland on April 8th and I'm going to be at the a tower theater in Philadelphia
on April the ninth.
Um,
all these dates are on billboard.com and uh,
that is that,
that is,
that is the podcast for this week.
I hope all you guys,
uh,
hope you enjoyed it.
Hope you learned some things.
I hope,
I hope I annoyed some pot heads out there.
Potheads I'm just fucking around it,
right.
Smoke it every goddamn day.
I don't give a shit.
All right,
but don't give me this horse shit that it's not addicting.
Alright.
You smoke it because you can't fucking deal.
Yeah.
I shouldn't even tell you this story.
I had a buddy of mine,
he was fucking,
he was working at a car dealership one time and he got high and there was
somebody looking at a car,
honey,
you know,
and they were bent down in front of the car and he got in the car and it was a
stick shift and he didn't press in the collection.
He turned the key in.
It lurched forward.
He hit the guy right in the head
and he tried to act.
He would never admit that he was high.
It was like,
dude,
it was,
he goes,
he,
he calls me up,
right?
He's like,
dude,
he leaves a message.
He's whispering.
That's how fucking scary as he's whispering into my phone.
Maybe he's at work.
I don't know.
Say
Yeah,
I,
I hit somebody with a car,
dude.
Aye.
I thought I had the car,
dude.
Dude,
I,
I thought I had the car neutral dude and I,
I went to turn the key and it,
dude,
I hit the guy in the head,
dude to call me.
Somehow we didn't get fired.
Uh,
that's another reason why I think we just worse than booze.
People would just cue that.
You know,
you can get fucking high at work.
No one fucking knows.
No one knows,
you know,
a little visor and a little fucking gum.
No one knows,
right?
You guys are bringing down this country with your fucking cookies.
You realize that your bunch of
Lazy Dorita Wheaton Sons of bitches
just sitting there getting baked.
Do you realize that your potheads of the reason why so many awful movies get
made
because they know,
they know people out there a smoking dope and then when they put it out on on,
they're going to fucking rent it and it doesn't only want us to be like remotely
funny and then Shit that wasn't even supposed to be funny.
It's going to be funny because he's fucking pot heads are going to be sitting
there.
They're going to be high giggling
like a bunch of school girls,
you know?
Yeah.
You pod has got a lot of fucking balls.
You realize that
you fucking disgusting fucking habit.
Passing it around to each other.
That's why.
That's why there's so many goddamn cold sores out there.
You know the number one cause it cold sores in this country.
It's you fucking potheads passing the things around each other.
Do you realize that?
You know,
I remember cracking open a beer.
I don't remember passing it around in nine other fucking people.
Hey,
let me get a swig of that.
Open your own.
You can't.
It's why I like weed man.
It's more so she'll gagged.
Go Fuck Yourself.
Don't you go take a fucking shower and take off those goddamn outback pants.
All right,
I'm sick of all right.
With your bracelet around your ankle,
right?
You're not more in touch with nature because you're smoking trees.
All right?
Get out there and get a fucking job straightened up.
Potheads you just spent the last decade of your life on a fucking couch.
You know,
when are you gonna put your helmet on?
Getting the Goddamn game?
Is that what you're gonna do?
You're gonna sit there
like some kept woman,
except you kept by yourself and you fucking awful habit.
I got to get high,
dude.
I can't deal unless I'm high.
You know you really going to sit there and act like you don't know that guy.
All Molly talk about as the alcoholics,
this is like the fucking broads.
All they do is talk about wife beaters,
but they never bring up gold digging whores.
Why don't you fucking get your Goddamn fucking pothead ass up off the couch and
go look in the fucking mirror?
Look,
look what you're doing to yourself.
Look at your eyes.
Feel your brain feels compressed.
I'm looking down,
my alkie knows that all you fucking pot heads,
there is a reason why weed is illegal and alcohol isn't all right cause alcohol
is better for you.
Alcohol is what a man does.
All right,
we'd is what some pussy does.
Who,
who can't afford to pay for a good pizza?
So he's got a fucking get himself so fucking disoriented that that's how
Domino's survives.
Those fucking assholes do you know,
dominoes makes such shitty pizza that actually potheads even fucking noticed.
They realized that.
So they actually had to have an ad campaign where they fucking admit that their
pizza sucks and that it stuck to the top of the box and it's completely
unacceptable,
right?
And now they're big ad campaign is we,
uh,
we admit that our pizza sucks and now we're going to start trying.
We've only been around for what,
30 fucking years now we're actually going to to make decent pizza,
right?
So you think automatically they're going to raise the price,
they're going to add to the quality.
This still selling like a large cheese pizza for five 99.
All right.
People.
You get what you pay for.
All right?
Don't order Domino's.
That's pothead pizza.
That's what those fucking drug users,
that's what that,
that's what they stick in their temple.
All right?
That's why they're so fucking dumb.
That's why it was the last time you talked to a smart pot head.
Have you ever,
you ever seen a pothead with initiative?
You know
you don't.
People are going to take that seriously and start sending me fucking emails
about,
well,
what about Bob Marley bed
really fucking call new kind of music?
Man.
He was fucking dead.
A lung cancer,
you know,
from smoking goddamn joints the size of a bus exhaust.
No different,
no different than a boom town or drinks himself to death at 28
you know,
I think you know,
I think you part it.
You guys have been on your high horse long enough.
I think it's time I fucking knocked you off a little bit.
Even going to notice you probably already off the horse laying in the grass,
right?
Letting a breeze go through your toes.
Is that what you did today?
Instead of going out and earning your fucking rent,
you're got to call your parents up again this week.
Hit him up for some more money because you ran out of fucking Cheetos.
You're too fucking old to have a full body.
Tam.
Why don't you go get a God damn job.
You son of a bitch.
All right.
There you go.
Once a week.
I got to try to piss off one group.
It keeps emails coming.
Um,
all right,
that's it.
That's the podcast for this week.
I want to thank everybody seriously,
and I'm not fucking around here like I was with the potheads there,
right?
So fucking don't get all fucking pissed off me.
And um,
I want to thank everybody who came out to my shows at the,
uh,
the Miamis symphony fucking,
Superman's house.
It's really what it looked like.
Um,
and I really hope a bunch of people show up in Utah,
uh,
and dopey.
Don't be stuck up comments.
All right,
with your fucking religion.
Okay.
I,
I don't need that.
I don't need you and your seven wives sitting there staring at me like I got a
fucking problem.
All right.
Fuck you.
And your legal orgy.
Yeah.
Okay.
I think that's it.
All right.
That's the podcast.
Everybody go fuck yourselves.
I'll talk to you next week.
Have a good week.
Don't talk any shit.
I'll talk some shit.
Don't take any shit.
There we go.
That's it.
I'm going to go get a sunburn.
I'll see you.
[inaudible]
Sharon,
we can bring it to them.
Come on,
girl.
If you want to go
and if tomorrow,
fine.
Just to gather right
the way we,
uh,
would you mind
sharing the night?
[inaudible].